zone europe bonjour et bienvenue dans un
europe / sensation une émission
enregistrée au parlement européen de
bruxelles est réalisée en association
avec tv 78 voici tout de suite le
sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé marque boeing a sera mon
invité l'occasion d'évoquer les étapes
du déconfinement la stratégie de
vaccination dans l'union européenne et
le certificat vers la construction
européenne et les personnages
emblématiques nous vous parlerons de
nicole fontaine voyager dans l'assiette
direction l'europe de l'est aujourd'hui
avec la recette de la bap car une
brioche très moelleuse des expressions
populaires renoncer à deviner les
français disent donner sa langue au chat
les grecs disent avalé sa langue que
dit-on ailleurs c'est ce que nous
verrons à la fin de cette émission
mais avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple tout de suite zone
robe l'europe dans ma région
aujourd'hui je reçois martha de sidrac
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
sénatrice secrétaire de la commission
des affaires européennes est également
la nouvelle présidente de la maison de
l'europe des yvelines vous succéder à
l'ancien député pierre lequiller comment
vous êtes vous êtes vous retrouvé
embarqué dans cette aventure
alors écoutez je m'embarquais peut-être
un peu fort mais j'ai une vraie passion
européenne je suis à saint germain en
laye je suis saint germanoise de très
longue date
quand on habite dans une ville comme
saint germain en laye on ne peut pas ne
pas s'intéresser à l'europe
nous avons le lycée international nous
avons une forte communauté européenne et
moi même j'ai des origines bulgares par
ma mère donc l'europe est quelque chose
d'assez naturel chez moi et lorsque
pierre lequiller donc le président qui
étaient sortants et regin a le coin de
la secrétaire général m'ont contacté
pour me proposer de d'intégrer la maison
de l'europe
ma réponse positive finalement s'est
imposé assez aisément et j'en suis très
honorée et très heureuse de l'avoir
acceptée alors la maison de l'europe des
yvelines a été créé il y a un peu plus
de vingt ans par regina lecointe elle et
elle en est toujours à aujourd'hui elle
est secrétaire général vous l'avez dit
original lecointe comme la maison de
l'europe des yvelines ce sont un peu des
institutions quel regard portez-vous sur
cette longévité
ça prouve en fait justement que c'est
tout à fait logique que dans un
département comme le nôtre nous ayons
une maison de l'europe parce que nous
avons une population qui bouge nous
avons une population jeune aussie qui
voyage nous avons une population qui
s'intéressent à ce qui se passe en
dehors de nos frontières françaises
et comme la maison de l'europe à l'une
de ses missions c'est aussi d'encourager
la mobilité de nos jeunes
c'était un outil très intéressant
je dirais même important maintenant pour
aider à des jeunes de pouvoir découvrir
d'autres pays d'autres langues d'autres
cultures qui quand même font partie de
cette grande communauté européenne et je
crois que c'était assez naturel que nous
ayons une maison de l'europe dans les
yvelines et la mobilité justement des
jeunes c'était le point face est le
point central de la maison de l'europe
des yvelines
c'est l'un des points forts
effectivement delà de la maison des
yvelines de la maison de l'europe des
yvelines puisque vous savez que nous
essayons de répondre à des appels à
projets nous répondons aussi à beaucoup
de demandes qui peuvent émaner de
différentes institutions nous faisons
beaucoup de choses en partenariat y
compris avec des missions locales des
yvelines puisque ça permet à des jeunes
qui peut-être dans un cadre familial
n'aurait pas l'opportunité d'aller faire
un stage de découvrir un autre pays et
donc une autre culture
or la maison de l'europe est là pour ça
donc ça je trouve que c'est quelque
chose de très bien de très positif de
très encourageant je dirais même d'
enthousiasmant pour les jeunes et quels
sont les autres missions justement de la
maison de l'europe des usines de faire
connaître l'europe
je crois que c'est on peut partir par la
base c'est important puisque la maison
de l'europe des yvelines aussi a comme
vocation de sensibiliser nos scolaires
quel que soit leur âge à ce qu'est
l'europe aujourd'hui ce que la robe
l'europe apporté à leur propre pays mais
aussi ce que notre propre pays la france
peut apporter à l'europe
on a parlé de différents sujets à
différentes occasions que ce soit sur le
volet environnemental que ce soit sur le
volet touristique que ce soit sur le
volet industriel je pense qu'il est
nécessaire que nos concitoyens se
familiarisent avec l'union européenne
avec l'europe avec son histoire aussi et
que les échanges puisse se faire et moi
je suis convaincu que ça passe aussi par
notre jeunesse donc le cetc partenariat
que nous avons avec des établissements
me semble aller dans le bon sens mais au
bureau de la maison de l'europe vous
êtes entouré de deux vice-présidents
franck aida rédacteur en chef et
présentateur à m6 et stéphanie terre
proviseur adjoint du lycée le corbusier
à poissy et première adjointe à marly le
roi alors qu'est-ce qui vous rassemble
est ce que c'est la même envie de faire
connaître l'europe
oui je crois je crois je connais les
deux personnes que vous avez cités et
moi je me réjouis du tout le travail que
l'on aura à faire dans la continuité de
ce qui a été fait jusque là par regin a
lecointe et aussi par pierre lequiller
et
et maintenant les problématiques sont
peut-être différente on a le sujet du
break site qui nous a aussi beaucoup
occupé ces derniers mois il ya des
challenges à relever il est entré en jeu
auquel dont il faut se saisir quelle il
faut répondre et je pense que nous
allons faire allez je vais le dire un
bon job
j'espère et en votre en votre qualité de
présidente quelle énergie pensez-vous à
insuffler est ce que vous avez déjà des
envies des priorités sur lesquelles vous
travaillez avec les équipes de la
mission de la maison de l'europe parle
alors moi lorsque je me suis présenté
pour être puisque j'ai été élu par
l'école conseil d'administration dans
mes propos liminaire j'avais dit que je
souhaitais être je l'espère une très
bonne ambassadrice pour la maison de
l'europe des yvelines et donc c'est un
peu comme ça que je vois aussi ma
mission puisque je suis membre de la
commission des affaires européennes au
sénat nous avons donc des liens assez
forts c'est une commission qui est assez
dynamique nous auditionnons très
régulièrement que ce soit des
parlementaires européens que ce soit les
commissaires que ce soit notre ministre
clément bonne et donc j'espère pouvoir
être utile pour faire cette connexion
avec des instances qui sont au-delà
peut-être de notre territoire pour
pouvoir bénéficier de toute cette
expertise que l'on peut avoir en
national depuis le début de cette
interview vous évoquez justement un
dynamisme con con qu'on ressent bien
c'est justement une valeur importante
pour vous d'être d'être dynamique au
sein de la maison de l'europe oui oui
parce que pour toutes ces personnes et
tous ses concitoyens peut-être qu'ils ne
connaissent pas suffisamment l'europe
est ce que l'union européenne peut faire
l'union européenne c'est une véritable
ruche avec beaucoup de dynamisme et donc
je crois qu'il faut s'y intéresser de
près parce que c'est aussi comme ça que
nous français nous serons plus forts
ça peut paraître paradoxal ce que je
vous dis mais moi je crois beaucoup à la
au dynamisme collectif
aujourd'hui les enjeux sont mondiaux
vous savez quand vous avez des
puissances comme la chine comme les
etats-unis la russie
toutes ces puissances émergentes aussi
que l'on peut deviner ici et là l'europe
est nécessaire pour que des pays au sein
de l'union européenne puissent également
faire valoir leur propre vision du monde
et je pense que ce n'est vraiment que
unis et ensemble qu'on va pouvoir y
arriver
et très modestement nous dans la maison
de l'europe des yvelines et côté on va
essayer de faire ce travail là et alors
l'europe fait parfois débat certaines
personnes la critique alors d'un point
de vue personnel pour vous qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que l'union européenne quelle
image est ce que vous en avez à titre
personnel images moi j'ai une image
assez positive même si je peux être
critique ici et là sur un certain nombre
de sujets on a eu dernièrement cette
polémique oui on peut dire polémique
autour de la vaccination et des vaccins
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut que tout
en aimant et en essayant d'aider d'une
certaine manière aussi l'union
européenne à mieux se construire nous
sommes en éternel évolution ne pas
perdre de vue et être critique on n'est
pas dans une béatitude est dans une
espèce de l'admiration sans borne je ne
suis pas du tout dans cet état d'esprit
avoir la capacité de critiquer ce qui ne
va pas pour pouvoir l'améliorer pour que
ça ne se reproduise pas pour que nous
puissions là encore avancer tous au
mieux et je crois qu'il est très
important que chacun de nous contribue à
tisser ce lien entre nous on a bien vu
qu'il ya il peut y avoir des distorsions
des incompréhensions entre peuples
européens
et ça je crois que une institution comme
la maison de l'europe peut aider à
casser certaines barrières qui peut y
avoir certaines incompréhensions des
voix de nos concitoyens lorsque
quelqu'un m'interroge mais là l'union
européenne à faire n'importe quoi c'est
quoi ces décisions du conseil c'est quoi
ces décisions de la commission c'est
quoi ces décisions du parlement à nous
membres de l'ami de la maison de laurent
faire valoir tout cela à l'expliquer la
compagnie avec beaucoup de pédagogie et
je crois que c'est vraiment le sens même
de ce qu'une institution peut faire dans
nos territoires et on pourra révoquer
tous et toutes ces thématiques dans
d'autres émissions merci beaucoup marina
deuxième vague d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensations comme chaque semaine nous
vous faisons découvrir celles et ceux
qui ont participé à la construction
européenne
aujourd'hui nicole fontaine retour sur
son parcours avec la maison de l'europe
et le centre d'information europe
rect sous drop nicole fontaine est né le
16 janvier 1942 à grains de villy mobile
en france
elle étudie le droit - et à paris et
l'effectuer en doctorat en droit public
est diplômé de sciences po paris
avocate elle commence sa carrière
politique comme responsable des
relations entre les établissements
privés d'enseignement et les pouvoirs
publics
elle est élue eurodéputée en 1984 et y
occupe le vice présidence où elle se
consacre principalement à des projets
pour l'éducation des jeunes
la reconnaissance mutuelle des
qualifications universitaires et les
droits des femmes et l'occupent la
présidence du parlement européen de 1999
à 2002 et devient la deuxième femme
présidente de cette institution
dans son premier discours au conseil
européen à ton père en octobre 1999
elle souligne l'importance de tenir
compte des préoccupations quotidiennes
des européens elle plaide pour une
approche ambitieuse visant à doter
l'union une charte des droits
fondamentaux
elle signera la charte des droits
fondamentaux au nom du parlement
européen en décembre 2000 et l'oeuvre
pour réformer les méthodes de travail
parlement et de le rendre plus proche
des citoyens
durant son mandat elle supervise
l'adoption de l'euro et ses compétences
diplomatiques sont particulièrement
reconnue et l'obtient en 2000 une
poignée de main historique entre les
présidents des parlements israéliens et
palestiniens
elle quitte le parlement européen en
2002 et devient ministre de l'industrie
au sein du gouvernement français son
engagement pour les droits des femmes la
mène à la tête de la fondation celle qui
lutte contre l'exploitation sexuelle
réélu au parlement européen en 2004
nicole fontaine enseigne également au
sein de l'université de nice sophia
antipolis et de les csp europe tout au
long de sa vie elle participe au débat
pour améliorer les institutions
européennes
peu avant le référendum du brds excitée
elle écrit un livre briques site une
chance repenser l'europe
elle met en garde contre les risques
d'une europe fragile ces travaux
soutiennent la nécessité d'une europe
plus unie et démocratique qui réponde
mieux aux maisons de citoyens nicole
fontaine décède le 17 mai 2018 à l'âge
de 76 ans elle restera durant sont
vivantes l'usure prix pour récompenser
son engagement et son travail pour
l'europe notamment la médaille robert
schuman et la médaille de commandeur de
l'ordre national du mérite
zone europe l'invité politique
bonjour d'almunia bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputé belge membre du groupe de la
gauche au parlement européen vous êtes
également membre de la commission de
l'industrie de la recherche de l'énergie
merci de revenir avec nous dans un héros
qu une nouvelle fois pour refaire un
point sur la stratégie et la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par l'union
européenne vous vous êtes engagés pour
la transparence des contrats entre la
commission et les grands groupes
pharmaceutiques sur les vaccins quelques
mois après est-ce que vous avez été
entendu
on a certainement été entendus pour tout
le bruit qu'on a fait est ce qu on a été
écouté je ne pense pas je pense que la
commission européenne a été obligée de
publier une série de contrats avec très
peu de transparence finalement donc
beaucoup de sang sur beaucoup de partis
comme ça noirci pourquoi parce que les
grandes entreprises pharmaceutiques
n'ont pas voulu et donc il faut il nous
faut augmenter encore la pression
après bon on est content que au moins on
a obtenu une partie est non seulement
dans des petites salles de lecture
obscures à la commission européenne met
même à publier sur internet
donc ça montre qu'en mettant la pression
on peut obtenir deux victoires alors ces
contrats en tout cas elles n'ont pas été
totalement respecté les vaccins
astrazeneca ont connu des problèmes
d'approvisionnement on le sait toutes
les doses prévues ne sont pas arrivés à
temps la commission a d'ailleurs attaqué
en justice le groupe astrazeneca c'que
vous soutenez cette action en justice
elle a annoncé qu'elle voulait aller en
justice pour faire respecter les
contrats après faut voir si
effectivement ça va nous permettre de
faire respecter le contrat d'obtenir des
dédommagements
je suis plutôt sceptique par rapport à
ça mais surtout ça ne résout pas le
problème dans l'immédiat donc dans
l'immédiat nous avons besoin de plus de
vaccins en europe mais aussi au niveau
mondial est donc là on se trouve avec
commande il ya une pénurie qu'on va pas
pouvoir résoudre avec une
une action en justice qui va durer des
mois où voire des années alors pour
accélérer la vaccination vous avez
demandé aux grands groupes
pharmaceutiques qui partagent leurs
technologies aujourd'hui est ce que l'on
se donne tous les moyens pour vaincre ce
virus bah non c'est ça le problème je
veux dire en limitant la production des
vaccins parce que c'est ce qu'on fait
quand on maintient les brevets privé un
donc un brevet ça donne un monopole sur
un vaccin ou un médicament à une
entreprise ou à quelques entreprises en
dix ans aujourd'hui il n'y a que
certaines entreprises qui peuvent
produire le vaccin mais il ya des pays
qui n'en ont pas je veux dire ou très
peu on voit dans ce qu'on appelle les
pays en voie de développement qui manque
cruellement de vaccin donc libérant le
brevet faisons un transfert
technologique et alors tous ces pays qui
veulent le produit et qui peuvent de
produire parce que ces pays là ont des
usines donc on dit souvent non on peut
le produire qu'en occident c'est faux il
ya des usines partout dans le monde qui
peuvent le produire mais donnons le
droit à ces pays pour le faire
alors pourquoi les grands groupes
pharmaceutiques ont refusé notre
proposition que vous ont-ils répondu
quelles sont leurs arguments une
question de profit donc fighter est très
clair là dessus il se bat là non nous on
prévoit pas par exemple de nouvelles
capacités de production en dehors de
l'europe et des états unis avant la fin
de la pandémie
donc c'est une question évidemment ainsi
il organise la pénurie et peuvent aussi
augmenter les prix donc on a eu les
fuites de certaines
comment dire certains pdg de pfizer qui
disait à goldman sachs et c'était là
nous prévoyons d'augmenter les prix nous
voulons aller aujourd'hui on est à 15
heures et demie plus ou moins la dose on
va aller vers 19h30 dans le suivant
contrat de l'union européenne met
fighter aux états unis a annoncé qu'ils
voudraient aller jusqu'à 100 non à 148
euros la dose 148 euros la deux et donc
l'idée c'est le profit en vaut vraiment
cette contradiction entre profits et
santé publique et la commission
européenne allait lui clients elle n'a
aucun moyen de contrer cette stratégie
bien sûr que si d'ailleurs il ya une
proposition concrète au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce qui
est porté par une coalition de 118 pays
comme un même joe biden le président
américain est en train dé réfléchir à ce
que
il faudrait pas faire quelque chose sur
les brevets les suspendre et c'est à la
il ya la commission européenne est
obstinée elle n'écoute que big pharma et
donc elle n'ouvre absolument pas elle
est dans un dogmatisme assez inquiétante
elle devrait au niveau de l'om c'est
soutenir la proposition faite par ses
118 pays avec l'afrique l'afrique du sud
l'inde etc
il ya un moyen utilisons le et pourquoi
alors la commission européenne ne donne
pas c'est un signe positif à cette
mesure
quel est son intérêt dans cette histoire
mais l'intérêt je pensais qu'elle a une
vision idéologique qui est celle de les
entreprises pharmaceutiques celle des
partenaires et avec ça elle passe en
fait à côté de commandite d'une
divergence d'intérêts qui a je veux dire
ces entreprises pharmaceutiques ont un
intérêt qui est celui du profit privé
des actionnaires etc sont dans le court
terme c'est normal c'est leur leur
objectif si on veut sociale mais la
commission européenne devrait veiller
sur la santé publique de tous hélas ici
quand cette contradiction a tellement
claire entre vaccins pour tous au profit
pour quelques actionnaires
la commission européenne est en train
d'être du mauvais côté de l'histoire
dans l'actualité sanitaire s'est
notamment les variants qui se
multiplient encore en inde au brésil
notamment des mesures de restriction ont
été prises dans certains pays européens
notamment sur les voyages la situation
pourrait-elle avoir un impact c'est au
bout sur l'efficacité des vaccins est ce
que c'est une hypothèse qui préoccupe
votre commission dont la survie est bon
c'est l'efficacité des vaccins est
évidemment en premier lieu une question
médicale un donc mais le ce qui est vrai
c'est que plus le virus circule plus il
ya des risques va de deux ans variant
différent du virus que ça soit en
afrique du sud en inde etc et à chaque
variant nous devons nous poser la
question sur est-ce que ce vaccin est
encore efficace ou pas et donc c'est une
c'est une inquiétude parfois on la
réponse sera oui parfois peut-être la
réponse sera non mais donc et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut vraiment vacciner partout
dans le monde veut dire il faut protéger
les gens partout dans le monde parce que
si on se protège uniquement en europe en
belgique en france et c'est évidemment
on risque toujours d'avoir ce variant
qui nous vient d'ailleurs au delà du
côté tout simplement humanitaire humain
dire c'est pas correct que les gens
ailleurs doivent continuer à mourir
tandis qu il ya un vaccin disponible sur
le break simon maintenant la comparaison
d'associations de la crise notamment été
un prétexte pour comparer entre la
gestion entre les britanniques et les
européens
alors où nous enregistrons cette
émission près de 11 millions de
britanniques ont reçu déjà la deuxième
dose de vaccin tandis qu'en france par
exemple nous en sommes à 14 millions de
premières doses uniquement au jeu de la
comparaison les britanniques gagnent du
coup finalement négocié à 27 pour les
vaccins n'étaient pas une mauvaise
stratégie
mais moi je pense que ce n'était pas une
mauvaise idée à la base parce qu'on
pourrait dire faso à l'industrie
pharmaceutique on pèse plus en pèse plus
lourd si jamais on et 27 plutôt qu'un
seul pays
c'était l'art du monde c'était
l'argument et je pense que c'est un
argument qui a du sens le problème c'est
qu'après avec l attitude est ce que vous
allez vers ces négociations est ce que
vous allez vers ces négociations en
disant nous allons nous imposer nous
avons des revendications justes et c'est
un os que vous allez là en disant
écoutez on va accepter ce que les
industries pharmaceutiques nous donne on
accepte le prix qu'ils demandent
on accepte les conditions qu'elle posait
etc oui évidemment avec ça on se perd
mais ça c'est pas dû au fait que
on serait 27 ou un pays ça a à voir avec
la proche que vous avez des négociations
et là c'est clair qu'on doit changer on
doit rompre radicalement avec cette
approche de se prosterner devant
quelques multinationales pharmaceutiques
occidentales parce que quand même boris
johnson a gagné son duel face à l'union
européenne notamment chez moi je pense
que boris johnson aujourd'hui ce qu'il a
choisi de faire c'est effectivement dit
moi je donne priorité à une à certains
certaine partie de la population de la
vacciner plus rapidement mais le
problème dont on a discuté par rapport à
l'accès global reste pareil je dirais la
grande bretagne est une île n'est pas
isolée du reste du monde et donc en
disant voilà je protège aussi les
brevets donc j'accepte la pénurie et je
vais juste payer plus évidemment ou
payer plus ou accepter certaines
conditions plus favorables
évidemment il résout pas le problème
mondial est le défi que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est de résoudre le
problème mondial et je regrette un peu
qu'aujourd'hui on soit dans à l'union
européenne contre la grande bretagne
non c'est le monde entier contre le
virus il n'y a pas de deux matchs en
tout cas entre d'autres deux pays
autre sujet la commission européenne
souhaite la mise en place du passeport
vaccinale pour cet été en tout cas l'été
approche c'est un défi majeur pour le
tourisme notamment l' oms elle s'est
prononcée contre le 19 avril pour le ms
pas de certificats verts vaccinale gens
que cela engendrait des inégalités entre
les individus
alors je crois que au sein du parlement
européen tous les groupes sont contre
disons que il y aura une résolution qui
sera votée par le parlement européen et
qui sera
pas pareil et qui sera critique disons
par rapport à la position de la
commission européenne ce que je trouve
une bonne chose
ceci étant dit moi je préfère qu'on
n'ouvre pas cette porte du tout pour les
raisons évoquées par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
je pense qu'une fois qu'on commence à
attacher des droits au statut sanitaire
des quelqu'un c'est extrêmement c'est
une pente glissante finalement je veux
dire on est sur quelque chose droits
fondamentaux santé c'est vraiment
dangereux donc moi je préfère fermer
cette porte la tania bien
bien fermé après il est vrai que c'est
encore plus douteux aujourd'hui qu'en
plein de gens n'ont pas accès aux
vaccins savez parfois on prend oui mais
un certificat fièvre jaune il ya un
certificat oui mais là le vaccin il est
disponible si vous voulez aller dans un
pays
je sais pas
en afrique qui demande un certificat de
vaccination contre la fièvre jaune
vous pouvez avoir votre vaccin ici
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de gens qui
peut-être le voudrait mais qui n'y ont
pas accès donc c'est une double
discrimination qu'on risque d'instaurer
et donc je suis absolument pas favorable
à ça alors pas de passeport vaccinale
mais concrètement comment on fait cet
été pour le tourisme pour que les gens
puissent quand même vous voyagez mais la
question elle est beaucoup plus large
que les vaccins pour ça donc une
question de tests ya une question des
quarantaines qui a toute une série de
mesures
donc ça c'est une partie de l'histoire
une deuxième partie c'est exterminer le
virus jeudi exterminons le virus plutôt
que de dire ah oui on accepte qu'il ya
des gens qui vont devoir vivre avec le
virus qui ne seront pas vaccinés et
d'autres qui auront droit je dis c'est
quoi comme comme raisonnement est alors
ceux qui ne seront peut être pas
vacciner à temps parce que la campagne
de vaccination prend du retard comme les
jeunes on va dire aux jeunes vous pouvez
pas voyager vos grands pères à vos
grands-mères oui mais vous non ça n'a
pas de sens comme ça on construit
vraiment une europe avec avec des
discriminations à deux vitesses qui
discrimine sur base vraiment de quelque
chose qui dès parle même pas de votre
volonté
donc même pas de votre volonté parce que
c'est pas vous qui décidez aujourd'hui
si vous avez accès ou pas vaccin merci
ma boîte en cas de très haut niveau dans
une europe / sensations je rappelle que
vous êtes eurodéputés belges membres de
l'ago du groupe de la gauche au
parlement européen les membres de la
commission de l'industrie de la
recherche et de l'énergie
voyager dans l'assiette nous vous
faisons découvrir cette semaine la
recette de la barca une pâtisserie de
l'europe de l'est
suivez les conseils de nikolas
brouillard de la mûre un gay à paris
sonne europe voyage
bonjour nikolas brouillard de la
meringue et à paris je vais vous
présenter la recette de la bap car alors
là bas est d'origine des pays de l'est
puis il exactement de la pologne et elle
a beaucoup voyagé
jusqu aux états unis d'ailleurs et elle
est revenue à la mode aujourd'hui
et en fait c'est une sorte on va dire de
brioches donc moi je l'adapté plutôt en
pâte à brioche
parce que sinon la pâte d'origine est un
petit peu sèche et qui est resté avec à
l'intérieur différents goûts et ensuite
trempé carrément dans un sirop dans
notre pâte à brioche ça c'est un kilo de
farine par exemple c'est 100 g de sucre
c'est 50 g de levure 20 grammes de sel
pour ce qui ne va pas tu es à peu près
600 g duff dedans voilà alors nous
allons commencer par étaler la pâte
nous allons donc pour la maintenant
l'état les et la couper en la taille de
notre bape cas alors je vais mettre un
mélange de beurre et de chocolat voilà
sur la pâte que je vais étaler et
ensuite je vais rouler très rapidement
la pâte sur elle même voilà dire qu'en
fait c'est un mélange de chocolat et de
beurre avec un petit peu de sucre pour
le maintenir
voilà il va durcir et à l'intérieur de
la pâte et c'est ce qui va créer
voilà notre barque a donc vous voyez une
fois qu'on a roulé la pâte sur elle-même
on retrouve notre patte et notre
chocolat on va couper ce cylindre en
deux voilà et nous allons le trait c'est
donc en fait on peut simplement voilà
et voilà notre base car une fois qu'on
les a tressé on va les laisser pousser
pendant une heure à peu près à 25 30
degrés comme j dans une pièce ou au
dessus d'un radiateur pour nous on se
sert évidemment notre matériel
et voilà vous voyez ça commence à
prendre du volume
au bout d'une heure notre s ont bien
poussé
voilà mais maintenant elles vont aller
au four pendant 15 minutes
voilà ça fait quinze minutes donc
maintenant on va passer au final le
climat s'est passé un petit peu de sirop
voilà pour les faire briller pour garder
le moelleux de la barca et voilà c'est
fini
les expressions populaires renoncer à
deviner les français disent donner sa
langue au chat
que dit-on ailleurs regardez zone europe
expression d'ici et d'ailleurs oui mais
c'est que signifie jeter la serviette à
l'espagne on dit dai bingguo le gâteau
donner sa langue au chat
en italie on dit italie espagne cela
veut dire jeu télé bougez zone europe
c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui merci aux
équipes techniques du parlement européen
de bruxelles
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de zone
europe
bonne soirée sonne robe sûr sensation